o we'd have yet another sitting senator calling
for the impeachment of President Donald Trump.
And
it's Cory booker.
Cory Booker is adding his name to the list.
Cory Booker of course, is also running for
president and he's pulling around two as I
showed you earlier on in the show.
And this is not necessarily once again a call
for the Senate to remove Donald Trump.
It's a call for the start of proceedings in
the house.
Cory Booker tweeting this administration has
continued to stonewall Congress's oversight
beginning impeachment proceedings is the only
path forward.
So we now have three sitting senators, all
democrats calling for impeachment proceedings.
We've got Elizabeth Warren, Camilla Harris,
and Cory booker.
Interestingly, all three of them are running
for president.
We have any number of democratic members of
the house who have already said, so, uh, including
Elijah Cummings and many others.
And then we also have, as I told you yesterday,
Republican Congressman Justin Amash who says
it is time to start impeachment proceedings
against Donald Trump.
Now on the other hand of this, you have still
speaker of the house, Nancy Pelosi, who says,
uh, we should not move forward on impeachment
and that it would be either a distraction.
Trump's not worth it or whatever else is,
is a, uh, the latest argument that she has
made.
Here's my bottom line on this.
You're not going to successfully remove Trump
from the White House sooner than you could
just vote them out via an impeachment proceeding
period.
Right?
I mean, Republicans are not going to come
to the side of impeachment.
Uh, you're not going to get between now and
January of 2021, uh, impeachment debate, impeachment
of, uh, articles, a full trial and conviction
by the Senate and the removal of the president
of the United States.
You're just not going to, okay.
So the strategy needs to be calculated or
evaluated knowing that the impeachment process
itself is not going to be what removes Donald
Trump.
So the reasons not to go down the impeachment
path, at least with starting debate in the
house are as we've heard before, it might
reinvigorate Donald Trump's base.
If Democrats pushed this, it could really
fire up Trump's base.
I don't think that's a very good argument.
Trump's base is already voting for him.
They are effectively unreachable by reason.
Okay.
Number two, it could distract from the agenda
and the platforms of the 2020 Democratic candidates.
And, uh, in doing so, it could inadvertently
help Donald Trump get reelected in 2020.
I don't believe that that's a reasonable concern
either because we are talking about members
of the House of Representatives starting debate,
bringing in witnesses, getting testimony on
the record.
Meanwhile, the 2020 Democratic candidates
can keep just talking about policy and issues.
Debates start next month and there's another
debate in July.
So I don't think that that is a concern.
And what you have to understand, I know I've
been saying this a lot, most Americans don't
know what's in the Mueller report.
Okay?
Mueller statement yesterday was essentially
Mueller begging people read the damn report.
Even though Donald Trump's base could get
more fired up by the impeachment debate starting
in the house, they're already voting for Trump.
Who cares if they're more fired up?
The impeachment debate could put the content
of the Mueller report front and center and
there is way more of a chance of reaching
people who have no idea what's in the report
or people who fell for the bar letter, Hook,
line and sinker and fell for no collusion,
no obstruction, hook, line and sinker.
And it might get them to realize that, wait
a second.
Molar says sustained substantial evidence
of obstruction that could damage Trump's chances
of reelection in 2020 and there are two different
ways that the impeachment debate could damage
Trump without actually being what removes
him.
So the, again, impeachment is not going to
remove Trump sooner than he could be voted
out.
It's just we're very close to the election
at this point and Republicans show no signs
that they would actually remove Trump no matter
what he did.
Republicans in the Senate, the first way that
the impeachment debate could damage Trump
is that it will simply distract from Trump's
campaign.
Right?
Media is going to cover.
We have to, you know, for all the bad things
that corporate media does, we can think about
how we can use corporate media to our advantage
and having the impeachment debate on the floor
of the house.
We'll get media coverage.
Any media coverage of impeachment debate is
time that is not being spent on the case that
Donald Trump is going to be making for his
own reelection.
That's a very good thing for whoever ultimately
is the nominee in 2020 and number two, the
fact that there is this cloud of impeachment
debate over Donald Trump in and of itself
could simply be damaging to Donald Trump and
how it influences less engaged voters to vote.
How it influences moderate voters or independence
or whoever else the information itself, right?
If only a few percent of the country has read
the report, impeachment proceedings that pushed
the content public could damage Donald Trump's
reelection chances as well.
So I think that this is something democrats
should do right away.
I've seen the right wingers who say, you're
going to help Trump if you do anything related
to impeachment, um, because you're gonna make
20, 20 about impeachment instead of about
issues.
That's not true.
Let the house have their proceedings, let
the house bring testimony.
The candidates can keep campaigning on issues
and ideas, period.
These are two different things.
It's not even, we can walk and chew gum at
the same time.
It's one person can be doing the chewing,
the gum, the gum, the other person is doing
the walking.
We're talking about the House of Representatives
as compared to the 2020 Democratic candidates.
That's not a concern.
They should do it
right away.